I recently read a comment by someone using the Joe Tippen's protocol. Again, the Joe Tippen's
protocol is the fenben dissolve protocol. That they stopped their fenben dissolve because
their liver enzymes increased. We talked about that on our call last week in a couple of weeks
ago. But then they learned that if the increase in the liver enzymes was due to cancer cell destruction,
could that be true? How does cancer cell die off alter your labs? Well,
cancer cell die off. Let's say, let's say you have a breast tumor. Let's say it's not in the liver.
So any tumor that's not in the liver, and you have die off of that tumor, could it cause
an increase in liver enzymes? The liver enzymes that we'd be looking at would be AST,
ALT and alkaline phosphatase. So understand, when a cancer cell dies, so when you're killing
a tumor, killing a cancer, there are several different ways that cells can die. One
set way, the normal program cell that is called apoptosis, that's basically a recycling of the cell,
the cell blems it on itself. That's determined to use blebbing. And then it basically,
through the lysosomes, breaks up the cell and recycles the cell matter. And it's producing very little,
what's called endotoxins. And endotoxin is a toxin that now has to be detoxified through the
liver pathways because of a cell death. So in apoptosis, there is very little endotoxin production
so it is not going to overwhelm the liver or hinder detoxification pathways or block detoxification
pathways. And the cell death through apoptosis is not going to increase ALT, AST and alkaline phosphatase.
Second way, cancer cells die is through a pathological cell death and that's set through cell
lysis. So that's like the cell just exploding because it's dying through pathological death.
And you can get some apoptosis taking place through natural cell death like through the rife
machine and through using herbs and through immune stimulation. It's going to be mainly apoptosis.
But certain alternative therapies can cause cell lysis too. So lysis is an exploding of the cell.
It's not recycling of the cell material. You're going to get a spillage of that cell material. And then
that cell material is going to build up in the extra cellular matrix. That's the matrix of fluid
and waste that's around cells that is then carried through the lymph system back to the
needle system and then carried through the liver and it has to be detoxified through the liver.
So what a cell explodes dies through lysis. It's going to produce a lot of endotoxins that
that has to be detoxified. So could that cause an increase in ALT, AST in alkaline phosphatase?
The answer to that is log explanation to the answer being maybe. Usually not. Usually what is going
to cause an excess, it can make you, so what would that cause? It could make you feel yucky when you
have excess endotoxins. It could make you feel ill. It could make you feel fatigued,
flu-ish. But by overwhelming the liver detox pathways with normal toxins that the liver that is
not poisoned to the liver, it will just, the liver will reject it. You know, the liver will have
a no vacancy sign when blood is coming into it and trying to dump its waste. So all this waste from
cell lysis is going to have been carried through the lymph system into the blood system, have to go
into the liver and if the liver is full, it's going to put up its no vacancy sign and it's not going
to accept that excess waste. So if you had excess lysis like quick cell death, you could feel the
effects of that, that waste in the blood being deposited in other parts of the body and it could
cause fatigue, it could cause just bluish type symptoms. That would be what would be called a
herxideware reaction. That's not going to elevate your liver enzymes. What will elevate your liver
enzymes? If your liver is injured, so excess waste that is natural, quote, unquote waste products,
is not going to injure your liver. What would injure your liver is poisons. So what would injure your
liver? What could possibly injure one's liver if they're getting cell destruction, pathological
destruction? Using something that is pathologically destroying the cell, aka chemotherapy. So if a
person is doing radiation or chemotherapy and causing cell lysis, it's not the cell lysis that's going
to increase the cell, increase the liver enzymes. It would be the chemotherapy or the radiation
that would damage the liver and cause the elevation of those enzymes. So I would disagree with this
comment. I highly doubt if it was cancer cell destruction raising the liver enzyme cults
because cancer cell destruction still, if you destroy a cancer cell, it's still your living tissue.
It's still your own human tissue. It's not a poison that you're destroying. It's not some enemy
from outside. It's your own cells. That's not going to damage the liver. The liver is damaged,
it's injured. That's what you're going to have elevation of AST, ALT and alkaline phosphates
in the liver because if the cause of those raised numbers are from the liver. So I don't think so.
So I don't think that's true. Even if it was true, even if that was true,
that we could prove that that was a true statement, you still have to pause this therapy
because your damaging the liver, whatever is causing the elevation of the AST, ALT,
and alkaline phosphates cannot continue. You can't say, oh, it's just because you're killing
cancer cells, so that's a good problem to have. I can deal with it if it's a pain or if it's a symptom
like that, but no, you could have liver failure and you could die from liver failure. No, you can't do
that. So regardless, it doesn't make any difference. You'd still have to pause the therapy. So
now, I understand a lot of people are doing fed men while they're doing chemotherapy or doing
something else, and it might not be the fed men that's causing it. It could be the chemotherapy.
It could be the other drug you're taking. It could be that it literally could be the
Tylenol you're taking. Do you realize that 15,000 people a year die of Tylenol poisoning?
Well, how is that? Because it causes liver toxicity. Guarantee you before they died of the Tylenol
poisoning. They're ill and they had elevated liver enzymes. So there's lots of things that can
damage the liver and most of the time it's going to be drugs. So even though even a good drug,
that bed is all great drug to kill cancer, but it can't injured the liver. So you have to back off
on it. So that's why you're going to do fed men, you do Ivermectin, you're going to do anything like
that. You need to be running a complete metabolic panel so that we can look at those liver
enzymes. You don't want to take the chance of, oh, I just feel so achy because I'm killing the
cancer. So that's a good thing. No, we got to look at it. You feel achy because you're killing your
liver and you could die of liver toxicity and die of liver failure from the therapy. Not a good thing.
So we got to investigate those things. So promise me you'll look at that.